Okay, we should be live.
Why do I not see
I don't see my dots like my uh my stats?
Where the heck is the chat?
I don't understand how this happened.
I don't see my chats off.
The heck did OBS just do?
Are we live?
Apparently,
it works. All right. Well, we're just
going to use it like this today.
Actually, that's kind of nice. There
will be uh less distraction, a little
less chat interaction today, I suppose.
I still have it up, though. Uh the one
that's on my overlay.
Hey, Liberty. Yeah, I still can see it.
Okay, so here's what we'll do. We will
I'm going to move this up here. I'm
going to move this down here so at least
I can see the chat more easily.
I won't totally miss everything and
today is going to be a pretty focused
uh focused day.
We have a lot to get done. We have some
decisions to make.
First, I want to show something and
we'll actually test something myself.
So really really crappy clogged port of
uh the encoder.
Okay, that's good speed, but that's a
tiny net.
600k.
So I mean that's really not ideal.
So we will be able to test this. I think
this will be the last one. So here's the
issue. Let me kind of explain what I'm
thinking through at the moment. So
on one hand, the models have actually
gotten good enough that you can use them
to correctly port
um pretty tough chunks of code. Like
look at this.
So this is the entire neural mo3
encoder. Um now on the other hand
nothing here is actually hard because
everything is really verifiable like you
literally run tests against the original
implementation like line by line or bit
by bit. So this is something that would
be very very tedious for a person to do
but not hard and uh the actual code
that's being used here it sucks. So it's
correct but this code is awful. This is
like hard-coded, unmaintainable,
complete and utter garbage. Um,
and like pretty obviously so.
And it feels pretty [ __ ] to have to like
have the workflow be to attempt to clean
up garbage because the problem is like
you end up incrementally cleaning up
garbage and you're always left with
some. It's very difficult to get the
whole thing cleaned up, but it is way
way faster.
I really hate this timeline. I really,
really hate this timeline. I I suppose
so.
Let me think what are my options here.
First of all, we don't have to do neural
MMO first. This is the last end. And
this is really ultimately this is the
tough one. Um
All these IM to calls go away if we just
use QDNN for the coms.
All this intermediate crap probably goes
away if we just use QDN for the coms.
And it gets faster.
Okay. So, this is one of the things for
today. The main thing I want to have
done for um for Puffer,
we need to have
2048 mazes, breakout,
we need to have 2048 mazes, breakout, and neural MMO all working well. I think
and neural MMO all working well. I think
that is the thing that will convince me
that the implementation is good.
And then we need to have code cleaned up
of those
2048 might need a very small custom
network. You get a chance to benchmark
uh 4.0 against the fixed 2048. No, we
were already 20 uh we're already
underperforming even before that on 40.
Like I just ran this sweep.
Uh this is on the old version of 2048.
So on the old version of 2048, the best
result we have is 27,000 average score
in 11 minutes of training. So I have to
go look at this network today and then
we're going to merge the fix in. We'll
make those changes. Uh we're going to
have to rerun some benchmarks here
though,
but things are already a little off
here.
Um okay, so we have 2048 to look at.
We have
neural MMO is the tough network encoder,
right? And the other one was mazes.
Mazes is very simple.
Yeah, mazes is very simple.
Mazes should probably be
the priority
because it has the fewest things that
can go wrong in it, I believe.
Right.
Believe Mazes has the fewest things that
can go wrong.
I forget if I did this one. I think I
did.
Cool.
Now,
there are a few different benchmarks
we're going to want to run here, right?
So, we're going to run the original 30
grid so that we can figure this out.
This run is kind of cool for uh 2048.
We'll get this one for later.
there.
This one's cool.
This one, I believe, is better as well.
We'll check this in a bit.
So, this is Puffer 3.
900k SPS.
We'll let this go for a bit.
Let me check out some in the meantime
here.
So, we'll have time for sport. So, let's
just do layers.
It's a clear benefit up to 512.
Hey, Jazz, we have a whole bunch of
things to fix. Mainly, it's we need
baselines actually working for all our M
correctly.
crunch the OBS window down a little bit
more so I can see
What other things would be interesting
to know here?
See, we're getting very stupid clip
coefficients with this.
So, this is still suspicious.
Okay. I think mazes will be a better uh
setup though to play with this
depending on if this is stable.
Okay. Well, we'll have this here at
least.
Just joined didn't see the previous
message.
Uh we're currently working on at the
moment
we're getting the grid environment which
is mazes. We're benchmarking this from
30. We're going to see how it does in
40. Probably going to have to queue a
sweep for this.
We basically need to have experiments
going 24/7 now though on uh the training
on various different environments. We
got to work on closing the gap in uh
training perf and making sure that
everything is still stable and good.
Uh, this number is also useful though
that we have here. I remember this being
the best we could possibly find in
Puffer 3. the trains at
sub 900k fps
auto speak with my attorneys.
Oh, that's fine. How's the chat spot
going, Jess?
go take a look. Let's not waste time. In
the meantime, we'll look at these runs.
what are the graphs look like on this?
Super clean graphs
You know, it's weird that it's like
it looks like you could just run these
for longer and have it do better.
We could try that.
There is the thing with the learning
rates though.
Well, at least our 30 benchmark is
working as expected. I remember this
being uh the hard end.
You want to get 0.9 something like 0.95
0.9 whatever
very clean
we'll have to do
oops
x log
there you go
so this is the training curve for mazes
Okay.
All this
and then our goal will be to replicate
this on buffer four.
This one is a very high confidence test.
And we'll be able to test a few
different setups for this as well. So
this is a 2.2 million parameter policy.
I believe this was just one layer LSTM 5
hidden dim.
We will look though what I ended up uh
putting in here.
It's actually puffer should be faster on
this. I wonder if this is like small
mini batches or something weird.
Start pulling this up just so we have
it.
Uh
3.0
Interestingly, we have it set to one end
one vector.
Few tests I want to do. Sweeps are
automated. Want to More lightweight
CNN's just need better hypers.
That's fair enough.
1024 ages
max size
These are now just called beta 1.
Horizon.
These are all still valid.
Did this have num mini batches beard on
it? I don't believe so.
Let's go double check.
This does not have n many badges. Okay.
Does it have update epochs? Yes.
So then we don't have to worry about
this. This is fine.
We're just good.
And we can start on this at the very
least. This should be runnable.
Oh yeah. How big was this policy? 2.2
million parameters, right?
Oops. I got some messages to read. Hang
on. Let me get this run going and then
I'll read through messages.
Non. Wait.
CNN arch works too. 2D whether it will
be equal or better which is slow. So
it's equal to speed improvement. Self
plane 4 would help. Spencer tells me you
got non-turnbased version work. I didn't
say I got it to work. I said I figured
out how to do it. Um I didn't implement
it. Hi Joseph. Absolutely loved your
last video. Thanks to you and the
community for doing this. Thank you.
We will be uh
doing quite a bit of dev over the next
couple of days. There's going to be a
lot to do.
I am also just realizing here this is a
bigger network than we had before and we
are at triple the speed from before. So
I'd say that this is a win and uh this
is a win so far for puffer 4.
Now the question is whether this will be
as good.
and then we have this one.
So, by 100 million steps.
Uh, no. See, it's not as good as the
problem.
It was doing okay,
but it seems this is unstable.
Yeah, that's really disappointing.
It's really disappointing
now.
There's one other thing I need to look
at here because
we have this oddity where there's this
discrepancy to power three and it works
way better with this discrepancy.
So if I uncomment this,
this should bring it closer to puffer
three.
See, there's something seriously wrong
about that because this should be the
version that's closer to puffer
uh to puffer 3
unless we just have a massive bug.
Let me get rid of Oh crap. Not having
the freaking stream chat window up means
I can't ban these [ __ ]
Damn it.
Now I have to pull reream up in the
other window.
I forgot about the bot problem.
Damn it, Twitch.
I'm going to keep this open
on the other room just so I can ban
these guys.
I can't do it for the first one.
Let's go look at this because this is
very suspicious to me that it works
without this.
I'm gonna actually have to look at this
at the same time because I'm probably
just missing something dumb.
Okay, now I will go look for it myself.
Not something I'm exploring at the
moment. Is there any benefit to stuff
like MUP?
Uh, yes, there would be, Jeff. I haven't
had time to look into it. that one
specifically. It's mostly just learning
rate
and it would be quite helpful.
It make it the um it would make it
easier for the hyperparame search for
sure.
Okay, let's just see if we're doing
something completely stupid here. So,
rollouts valvalues.tes rollout.io Make
sure the bites
and roll that stuff here, right?
Am I doing the wrong bite order or
something? saying
The only thing I can think of is this
kernel being wrong.
Is there anything else weird?
Is there something weird with cuda
grapping?
There wouldn't be anything weird with
cudigraphing here, right?
This is outside the cudraph.
Else
it's outside the cudraph.
advantages from self advantages. Yes.
Like mini bag. Yes.
Oh, did I [ __ ]
That's test code.
Yeah, that was old test code.
This is why I can't be doing too many
projects at a time because I like leave
test stuff in and I forget.
Let's see if that brings it more in
line.
Good evening.
Morning for me.
Let's just see what this does for a bit.
Let's see if this nan's out or what
happens.
I mean, this was clearly
clearly bugged, right?
Yeah, I messed that up. But it's still
the thing is it's still not fixed. And I
do remember testing both of these.
And we can see it's completely blown
off, right?
So this old value thing, it's the exact
same.
It's the exact same if you're not
updating.
RL is training and simulation not for
language models.
See the problem here is that this
version
The version that kind of works is
definitely wrong.
The version that should work doesn't
work at all.
Did it really rebuild it?
Something's very very gray here.
It should be the same number of hypers.
No
policy
hidden size 512.
Wait, it really shouldn't be that far
off.
Is that a clue?
Four layers,
huh?
Oh, right, right, right. cuz I I forgot
that I added the third gate. Okay.
So, yeah, my nets are a little bit
bigger now.
Yeah, I did. I added the third gate.
Okay,
let's just try this real quick. I doubt
that this fixes it magically.
Puffer 4 is the latest version of Puffer
Lib. You can see demos on puffer.ai.
Uh, this version will be much much
faster and have a whole bunch of really
cool tech in it.
This is all public. This is all open
source.
Interesting. So there still it's not
like just a model size thing.
Try two layers just to be absolutely
sure.
Okay. Well, that's a major problem.
Did I get the mini bad size?
Beta one, beta 2, epsilon.
Did anything else? Did I like mess up?
No, these are all the same parameter
names, right?
That dynamic is really really wonky. It
shouldn't just be like
Definitely wasn't careful enough with
the experiments throughout this whole
thing.
How much parameters?
Tiny tiny number of parameters. Very
fast.
simple train with this?
Let's
Okay. So, maybe breakout's actually too
simple.
That would be kind of funny.
Yeah. So, breakout trains with either of
these. Okay. So, breakout's too simple
then.
Po kernel computes the ratio and new
value.
gain this much knowledge. Well, for what
I'm doing here, this requires like three
brain cells. Um, but for everything I'm
doing here normally, like I've been
doing this since I was 16. It's been or
15 almost half my life.
Will you make video resources? I've
already done that. If you look around,
I've done like I have so many resources
available already.
all of that.
It's um here all of my educational
stuff.
The best part, the best place to start
for that, it's all free. It's online.
If you just go to my ex, which is at JB
Barz,
this article here,
can I stick this in the chat? I'll put
it in the chat from your stream there.
And this is my more general one down
here.
See, I don't like this
float with strict grad logics. Brad
standard deviations.
Let me see the good way to do this
first. So, this is supposed to be
put them in. What do you mean I haven't
put them in a playlist? It's not It's
not just like watch this video and
you'll know what I know, right? Like,
you actually have to put in work.
There's it's like a series of like read
this, do this, like build this, you
know? It's a whole bunch of stuff.
You can't just watch a YouTube playlist
and gain like a ton of directly useful
knowledge in an area you're not already
experienced in.
I didn't do join
and because I wanted to do my own thing.
This is far far more interesting and
rewarding.
What is a pain in the ass some days?
This is one of them.
Um
graph MB new value.
Did I really just not update this
buff?
Wait,
this is fine. This is the index
Where's it past graph?
Does pass graph, right?
Is this the colonel? This is not a
colonel.
What am I doing here?
I see MV values getting passed in. MV
returns
this. Okay, this is like this is
essentially this is what I get for not
having cleaned up this code earlier.
Can I not update this? I think I can
just do this in place, right?
Yeah, this section of the code's really
bad.
Wait, where the heck does this even get
computed?
Does this get used at all or did I move
this
MB ratio?
It literally is only here.
Does it get computed in here?
Okay, so I see it and then it doesn't
ever get updated. Lovely.
That's just lovely.
Any sponsor for your model? How do you
afford? I mean, we're a company. We
build um we build high performance
simulations for reinforcement learning
for companies
and uh we get them integrated with our
tools. We do reinforcement learning,
R&D,
and we have the fastest tools out there,
bar none, in reinforcement learning. So,
it's a space that despite all the hype
on LLMs these days, there's still a
bunch of companies that do this. Uh,
it's a very different use case than can
be done with the AI you see in the news
these days. And
we do it very well.
It's not particularly expensive. No. Um,
we do have some hardware. We have, I
believe, 20 490s worth of hardware. Oh,
yeah. I'll be back there in like a month
probably. If you want to see uh my usual
funny stream setup that I'm at most of
the year,
you'll see this in the background in a
month or so. We have all the servers in
the background as well.
The gym warehouse plus server room.
Hey Joseph, how you can contribute to
the project? Depends on your background.
Um, if you are new to RL, check my guide
on X. If you're experienced in RL, then
the current state of things is we've got
a ton of low-level crap going into 40.
We're trying to get us like a very good
raw CUDA training back end that's not
the complete and utter mess that you see
here. Um, we're trying to get everything
benchmarked. We're trying to get all our
numeric checked. We're trying to get
experiments on all of our environments.
If you're not into the low-level side,
then there's always the contributing of
new environments. New environments are
always good. New environments, new
application areas are always good. Probe
environments that are designed
specifically for algorithmic tidbits
here and there are good. couple of open
areas of research as well that are uh
available to contributors once they have
an idea of the whole flow of everything
around here. There's quite a bit.
It's not a SAS company because the
software is free. It service is a
service.
I Hang on, folks. I need a couple
minutes like to focus on this and figure
out
what I have done here.
Well, it's clearly in the kernel.
Whatever is going on is clearly in the
kernel.
Oh, we just inline the ratio of
computation. I forgot to Damn it. Okay.
Well, that's annoying.
Does this thing take graphs?
No, this is part of the code that I
didn't get to cleaning up yet. Right.
I see.
beginning. Well, you just made that up
because that wasn't what I wrote in my
guide.
It's not at all what I would suggest you
do.
Yeah, see this is like entirely
self-inflicted. But I have to deal with
this now.
Where do values get computed?
deck puff
for train.
This will give you
values
Well, we have not done RL for Space
Company yet.
We had somebody submit a funny looking
orbital docker sim. It's pretty
interesting. Um,
the other day
We mostly we do core research
and then we do work professionally
wherever we currently have clients.
The simulation space is very broad.
CM systems. Yeah,
honestly just basic low-level depth is
one of the most valuable skills you can
have.
I actually would argue more so now
because now more than ever people are
just like not bothering to actually
understand how things work at all. And
that's why all the code sucks these
days.
Like even when you see me like
generating a big chunk of stuff here,
like it generates complete crap.
You can't just like use that and like
ship it and say, "Yep, project done."
Within a couple days of doing that, you
can basically make enough of a mess
within a couple of days that the project
is worthless.
Now, I have pre-existing constraints
here, right? I'm trying to like match
torch performance
um numeric. There's a bunch of stuff
that's going into this.
Does it completely break?
Not too encouraging, but let's try this
as a better test.
I got to fix that so you can't
accidentally build and then train on the
wrong one.
Okay. I mean, that's promising.
It's not completely broken,
That's definitely learning.
Um but that's very bad perfer
understanding.
Yes and no man. It's the problem is that
the like the models are trained on so
much garbage they just output such bad
code like
you just get inundated with crap is the
thing. And it's more crap than you can
reason about in a reasonable amount of
time.
this at least I think has a hope of
being reasonable, right? Because if
we're looking at this,
this is now the original hyperparameters
that I had optimized for a totally
different network architecture.
Oh, and of course I say that it's
unstable.
What do we do with this? Do we just
retweet breakout real quick
and understanding documentation?
Love, the one thing I'll say is they are
useful for sorting through large volumes
of other people's crap quickly because
like if you go try to understand Torch,
nobody understands Torch because Torch
is not made to be understood. torch just
like this giant mess. Um,
like some of the engineering in there is
honestly sort of a joke.
That's mostly what I've been trying to
do here. But the problem is it's like
stare too long with the void. The void
stares back into you. Um, and you know,
I've been like essentially trying to
port things from torch over to more
minimal implementations. But anytime you
give this thing any room to breathe at
all, it will come up with the dumbest
possible way to do things.
So, you need to be very, very careful
with it. But at the same time, it's
incredibly boring and mind-numbing,
which like it's just a very very bad
setup for helping you think about things
deeply.
Quickest quick quick quick check. Right.
I think we can just do breakout like
this.
I'm pretty sure Alec Bradford was
younger than that when he was doing GPT.
Terminal is so small on the screen. This
is a pretty large font size. If you're
watching on a phone, I can't really help
that.
How much kernel stuff did you do? Zero.
So
yes, chunks most of it is pretty easy to
pick up because I'm not really doing
so arch. I'm not really doing anything
that requires fancy synchronization
patterns at the moment.
They are mostly like elementwise or
sequent wise parallel operations.
So like there's going to I'm going to
have to go back and learn some uh some
fancier reduction techniques at some
point. But at the moment like that's not
even the main problem, right? The main
problem is just that there are a
thousand operations where there should
be like 10 operations if you look at
torch and there's 100,000 lines of code
where there should be like 2,000 lines
of code. So, I'm trying to at least get
Puffer down to three or 4 thousand lines
of code where we just have like this
relatively simple, compact thing that is
easy to understand, that is super fast,
actually running at like the speed that
you would expect out of your hardware if
you do the napkin math.
I mean, colleges would disagree with
you.
question nesting doll black boxes. Yeah,
I really don't like this design as well.
I don't ever like um having anything be
blackboxed in software. It's like this
very big tech idea that what you need to
do is you need to like put all the
complexity into a box and then obscure
it from whoever is using it so that they
don't worry their pretty little head up
for it. Um, this is an awful awful way
to build software
because of course like it's basically
like giving you a big bucket of
mismatched Legos and then trying to snap
things together, but none of the pieces
actually fit. So instead of just like,
you know, building a tower, you end up
doing a a massive jigsaw puzzle. That's
sort of what it feels like.
I'm just running this real quick to make
sure that this thing actually has stable
solves in it
and that it's just a retuning hyper
thing. And then if this is the case,
then we'll mess around with grid a
little bit. Probably start a sweep on
that.
The nice thing is that the the sweeps
are so so so fast now. You're running
many experiments per minute.
is this a real job description? It's not
like if you look at any of the AI
companies, you won't see that there's
anybody with the job title of data
scientist.
I think that's much more so for um
uh it's much more so for like scientific
labs and stuff or analytics firms
whatever where they just essentially
need somebody who can script Python and
call through large amounts of data.
I don't even know how many like things
have that title.
It's mostly like machine learning
engineer
researcher
scientist the like
and there's a lot of good material here
for um learning that I wish I had known
ahead of time. I think the single
biggest mistake I made was not not doing
enough low-level dev early enough
because my undergrad courses threw me
off of it. Like my undergrad courses
just made systems incredibly painful and
I didn't want to touch it for 10 years.
They gave me like completely the wrong
impression of um of what systems is
about.
Okay, so here we've got 4.7 seconds
already within the first few
experiments.
Noncuda stuff get a good improvement
arch. So
it depends um it it depends on the level
at which you allow me to ship stuff arch
because right now so right now the
Python um LSTM is like just calling this
big this big monolithic LSTM fernal. So,
if you're counting that, I'm allowed to
wrap my big uh mining grew cell
and just expose the whole mining grew
to torch, then yeah, that should get a
bump.
I have to find time to go wrap it, but
like yeah, that will get a bump.
But then like if you're going to insist,
well, what about the pure pietorch
stuff? Then no.
um if I'm not allowed to extend it or
whatever because a pie torch is really
just like it's irredeemable.
The design of torch just makes it
impossible to make stuff fast and
simple.
In fact, I think it just makes stuff
it's kind of impossible to make stuff
fast even or simple. Like you can't make
stuff fast and you can't really make
stuff simple. You can just kind of make
stuff look simple by lying about it and
hiding all the complexity.
just like giving people the completely
wrong impression of what's going on
under the hood,
which I don't like.
It honestly might be the case that
breakout is out living its youthfulness
here.
This seems too easy, doesn't it?
Like the fact that I could solve that
with a completely broken version of the
code in 3 seconds.
But then again, I guess it's not like a
completely broken version of the code.
What What would that be equivalent to?
I think it was just not updating.
It was kind of more like the vanilla PO,
wasn't it? Cuz it was just not using the
importance ratio update.
Yeah. So, it was kind of just like more
vanillaish PO, come to think of it.
Okay, that's not terrible.
Yeah, that's not terrible then.
It's actually not really an issue that
you could solve break up fast with their
original PO, but it does mean that we
need some harder tests that are still
fast for um our fancier methods.
Would 2048 be a better benchmark? No,
we're going to uh No, it's fine. Like,
we can update 2048. It doesn't make it a
worse benchmark because we make it
harder. That's fine.
like data analyst, data engineer, data
scientist,
some data to clean I work on. Yeah. So
it's like if that sounds interesting for
you then by all means not my cup of tea
though. None of the actual AI places
have um like data scientist data
engineer like they just don't it's not
the way they work for the most part.
Biceps too wide. Biceps must be wider.
You got to stay fit when you uh sit in a
chair and stream stuff all day. I'm
probably going to be streaming 10 plus
hours today. Definitely going to be
working 10 plus hours today. Uh probably
close to that tomorrow and at least 10
on Saturday as well.
Is going to be busy.
I don't want to run a full sweep. Let's
just say we're going to give this thing
what 70ish experiments maybe.
I kind of just want to get a picture of
this.
Yeah. So like Pong is just way too
simple because you can solve Pong with
really stupid methods. So, you know, you
can introduce bugs, like major major
bugs into your learning and still have
it solve pong just because the task is
too easy
of technical staff.
Open AI did that.
It's okay.
like
the problem they were trying to solve
with that was a real problem. I don't
know if they actually solved it in
practice or not.
enough to break over. I mean, that
really shouldn't affect it, though. If
you think about that loud, that
shouldn't affect it.
So, no, I do not work 12 I should not
work 12 hours a day, seven days a week.
Um, I generally don't advise people do
that in
like any sort of work that actually
requires you to think. I have done
longer hours than that before
um when I was younger and I just I
really do not recommend that unless the
work you're doing just is completely
stupid.
We're going to give this a few more
experiments cuz it's sort of starting to
fill out.
Running a lot of experiments that are
sort of too long is the thing.
Oops.
Where did my um
Where did my thing go? There it is.
you do get sore.
Um,
not all the time. You shouldn't be sore
every workout. If you're sore every
workout, you're probably not eating or
not sleeping or both.
I mean, I'm satisfied this is not
completely broken.
This is actually still too simple of a
test, isn't it?
Do you have any Do you have your
competitors on the market? No.
>> My competitors are uh let's see.
competitors would be uh
death, ignorance, and the madness of
men. Yeah, let's just list those as
competitors.
eight hours.
Yeah, you can like if you do that
calamario though, you'll quickly find
that like
I don't know, maybe you can, but for me,
if I do like I can do that for a few
weeks at a time on a new project, but
like at some point you're just your mind
is going to lose its sharpness. You need
like you can't just do that constantly.
Okay. Uh we pretty much have enough
experiments here.
I'm trying to think if there's any way
this would be abusable. I don't think
so. I think that if it can do this well,
it can't be completely broken.
Yes, it does arch. But that's not the
pro that's not the only class of
problems.
Like that's not the class of problems
we're looking at here, right? Like we've
used breakout for enough that we know
there's not really any way to abuse it.
Like it's a correct environment.
There's still other problems.
Still not stable.
It's still not stable sadly.
What? So this was this goes with the
fix, right?
And this is on the version that doesn't
have any clip.
How the heck is this still unstable?
Then
what sort of abuse? So Arch, I'm just
I'm basically
I have different versions of the
training algorithm
that I'm comparing.
And
if you have too simple of a problem,
your algorithm can have major major
issues and you could still solve like
pretty well.
So the thing is we have we have like a a
moderate issue.
So it can be hard to tell with some of
the simpler debug tests.
I'm a beginner. What should I learn to
get this level? Uh hang on.
Let me get you the guide
go through this. This is the RL one.
There's also the beginners one like the
programming in ML1 here.
These are my two highest rated pieces of
content.
I think we need to just end a sweep on
this, don't we?
Yeah. If I do it this way, it's just
going to do this all day.
Let me try a couple things first before
we do this.
Is there any There's not that much
reason to expect these to have changed,
is there?
Anything weird
under what Jess?
There's no way in hell that's
constitutional, right?
Defense Production Act.
The [ __ ] is that?
Uh stuff like that will probably just
get thrown out, I would imagine. Jeff
Okay, this is at least stable,
right?
Okay. So, this is actually this is
stable.
We can use this for the basis of a
sweep.
So, this is what we're going to do.
Um,
Sure as hell do not want to be managing
a publicly traded company.
Be way happier managing one or several
small private labs.
Okay, here's going to be the plan. Um,
we're going to go probably have to grab
a better config. No, this one works. All
right, so what we're going to do is we
are going to go I'm going to go uh grab
a tea. Grab a tea.
And then while we're running sweeps
on the grid environment to see if this
algorithm is good, I'm going to start
cleaning up the whole PO loss block of
code because that's totally what caused
this. That'll be another few hundred
lines cleaned up for the project. We'll
have the experiments running in the
background and we'll kind of go back and
forth on these for a good few hours
today. I will be back in a few.
What
I going to matrix row reduction.
What's this combo about?
Streamer two is just going over new PRs.
I will.
Yeah, Arch. It's just so much work on
40.
Lights out. Yeah, lights out will get
added.
We will add lights out. Of course, I'm
not going to ignore good NPRs.
They get delayed. They don't get
ignored.
Bringing cannons to a fight.
Yeah. Well,
the funny thing with buffer is it's
actually the 3 implementation is pretty
simple as far as it goes. Um, I would
argue that 40 is simpler than 3 0 or it
will be. Now, people are not going to
agree. They're like, "What do you mean?
You got all this CUDA and stuff?" Well,
yeah. The thing is torch isn't actually
simple. It kind of just lies to you
about all the complexity.
So if you want the thing that is
actually simple, it will be 40.
All right, let's make sure this is still
deterministic.
This is why you just ignore everything
that you see on online for many months
because most of the time it's just fake.
Okay, so I realized a couple of things.
So, um, first of all,
yeah, this these maze runs are going to
be good.
They are stable. Let's make sure.
Uhoh.
Double free or corruption.
Uh, that's a bad screw up.
Okay, here's the plan for today. Then we
fix this environment. We get this thing
sweeping correctly. And then actually we
go work on constellation because I'm
realizing I do need to clean up the PO
loss function. I need to clean up neural
MMO kernels. That's all brain dead work.
That's going to be mostly me staring at
Claude. I don't need to be doing that
live on stream. I don't need to be using
my productive hours on that. Um,
constellation is like complete
handcoded. No vibe crap. It's actually
pretty good. It just needs to be
completely finished. That'll be a nice
thing to work on. I can probably have
that finished while we're running
experiments over the next couple days in
between doing other stuff.
I can do some in the evenings. What I
can do is in the evenings I can do my uh
the more boring work
and yeah, we'll do it that way. So,
first of all, what the hell is this?
Let's figure this out.
Jess, we're not I can't do that right
now, man. There's so much stuff left. Do
you know how much work is left for 40?
This is technically supposed to be
releasing in a month. In fact, it's been
delayed like four times and it's
supposed to be releasing in a month. I
need this thing to at least be like
complete and stable before I look at
other stuff.
Constellation is the major major thing
that was intended from day one for the
update
that needs to be done first.
It came up so much.
Um
Well, hang on. This is totally going to
leak, isn't it?
Does it just not free the map?
Do we just leak the entire map?
Okay. It was supposed to have a shared
clothes.
It's constellation developing. It's
public.
I'll show you it in a bit, man. It's
like a local dashboard for um
like ton of it's meant to just let you
do a ton of experiments and not have
your stupid UI lag and uh just be able
to see. It's not like customizable like
Wabby is, but it's super snappy and it
does most of what you want.
and it'll load a bunch of data points
and not break.
And the nice thing about it is we get to
put it on the web.
So, um,
because it's C, right, we can file the
web assembly as well. So, we'll be able
to put all of our experiment data up on
the website as well.
There's another of the big motivators.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you can
technically I could even let you upload
your own data to it, right? Because it's
not running on our web server. It's
running locally. So, we don't have to
worry about security, right? Like you
can hack your own PC if you want.
that's better.
and num ends.
Let's just see if this works.
I want to get the constellation. I want
this to just be running in the
background. As long as it's stable,
we'll be good.
end of complexity is a configurable end
comparable end to the M fight
to learn and not implement.
Well, the M fight was just learned
instantly and it like wasn't the full
fight either. It was basically just the
um like the mage uh just like the
four was it? No, it didn't learn 40. It
literally just learned the mage running
and then um it did that really weird
method that people do to show off but
nobody actually uses where you hit me on
the m melee hand on the run back and
then you do uh mage on the way over. So
you do them both at the same time.
I actually are um not vibe coded from
scratch. I started working on I don't
know did you see this stream the inferno
one?
I actually want to finish this one at
one point and like not have this code
suck.
yeah, this
So, this is in this is running in C
here. I didn't load the enemy models in,
but I got the basic path finding
correct. So, you're standing here. The
mobs actually stack up correctly. So, I
got the mob pathing incorrect.
And um I was thinking if we could get
the entire infern inferno as an
environment, that would be pretty
freaking awesome.
I do think that puffer would solve it
quite cleanly, though.
Colonel launch and valid configuration
are lovely.
I think this is probably mismatch with
num ends.
Oh, dummy for this.
But that shouldn't cause the bug.
This is clean.
Okay, we'll keep on this a bit and
constellation as soon as we have this
running stable. This environment is very
very important for testing. So, it's
worth spending some time on it. It's
what the day is for. And um
Constellation. I may as well get
Constellation running locally though.
I'm waiting. We're not going to need
Claude hopefully at all.
Did I not have it set up locally?
Pretty sure I did have it set up
locally.
All right, welcome to Constellation. It
doesn't look all that cool with just one
environment in there. I think it just
has some breakout data at the moment.
Can probably get some more to load. Um,
we can get some more to load in.
But yeah, this is the dashboard. So you
have all the environments, got all your
matrix and everything. As you can see,
it responds instantly. There's no like
waiting for your absolutely god awful
web UI to load.
It's got like this 3D little uh this
little 3D renderer. This is a tene. This
will look this doesn't do much now, but
it looks very cool when you have more
data. Most of these honestly are for
when you have more environments sloped
in. And this is this one on the top
right is the main one that you'd want
otherwise.
Uh, this does seem to be running for
now. We'll see if this crashes.
Why the hell is this running experiments
that are like 10 mill steps?
Total time steps is going to be 20.
Let's do 8 to 29 so it doesn't do the
stupid small runs
Okay, I will keep this on my other
monitor and we'll do some constellation
dev
and I will see if that fails every so
often.
Okay,
installation.
is
several things we need to improve here.
I think the first one was going to be
the data copying feature, right?
let's do agent steps first. gamma.
Okay, so here we have gamma.
Should we run ourselves like a quick few
sweeps on this to get some data?
I think we need to, right? Can we just
like
Yeah. So this is the script for
processing.
No, this is not. Where is it then? Cash
data.
Okay. This is the script that we have
now for caching data.
Just get a few experiments worth of data
locally so we can play around with them.
The main thing that I want to do with
constellation today, I want to change
the way that we are pre-processing some
of the individual elements, how we're
handling specific keys in the hypers.
And um
I'd like to have the axes for the plots
better reflect the um well the scaling
for the axis be more reasonable.
Essentially,
there's a transformation that's applied
to log data that's not correct for some
types of data, like some types of
hypers.
Frame/ learning. Right. Cool. So,
why is this not in here?
Ah, it's just not under training.
That guy's messed up.
This is actually a good reason to not
do a custom data uploads to the website
because the format there will change.
Let this give us a few more experiments
worth of data
Let's not wait for this too long. We
actually probably just be using foam for
these. Even better.
Super super quick experiments.
Uh there should be a hidden size.
It's probably the same bloody thing,
huh?
Okay, let's just do it this way for now
then instead so we don't have to keep
rerunning these
really
just not logging. Now
Wonder if this even works.
No, we haven't updated Pong yet.
Oh,
all right. I mean, we have um
Stupid.
God damn. 0.5
more experiments.
See if it gets a couple quick ones.
4 million parameters, huh?
We're not waiting for this one.
skip name three data points.
Cool.
This will do
data
now.
This doesn't use hypers at all.
It's kind of funny.
Oh, I see. It's for the t- snake.
That's probably a decent thing to have
then.
Do we do any sort of weird transforms on
this?
We have this like logic normal transform
on it
like this.
See? Okay, so I think that we have a
plan at the least. So the plan is going
to be that we try to get the data in raw
um and we attempt from there to probably
apply the transform in the C. We
definitely want less in this script.
I think ideally actually the ideal case
is we have nothing in this script except
the bloody tea snake.
And there's a restroom. I got to grab
more tea. Give me a few minutes. I will
be back and then we will proceed.
right, grabbing tea. I'll be back in a
sec.
Okay, let's get this working. So,
first thing,
first thing
I think what we should do
You're just using the last point which
is not great.
Okay. So, we actually do have to think a
little bit about the design of this. Um,
do we want end params in here?
I think no, right?
Yeah, I think just no.
So if we don't want n par in here,
then what we do is
balancing a couple objectives here. I
don't actually want
I think we don't worry about like what
data we're throwing away here because
we kind of just assume that we'll have
the master copy.
Um,
so if we're not worried about throwing
away data,
then
I think it would actually be more
robust.
I think it is actually legitimately
better. We just try hard to specify
these.
So now
learning rate
data
of N's
Oh, because it doesn't get the speed
key. It's lovely.
That's annoying.
Okay. Well, I mean, this is basically
just going to be jamming some data stuff
for a while. I'm going to throw some
macaron music on for myself, and we're
kind of just going to chill and jam uh
jam some code for a bit. Let me make
sure.
We'll take a quick look at the
experiments first, just to make sure
it's doing something.
Oh yeah. I It's not like a super
encouraging sweep or anything, but it's
doing something at least.
So, let's do this. Let's get
Constellation going and we'll go from
there.
Put this up there and I'll still explain
somewhat what I'm doing along the way a
little bit. All right. So, first thing
is just going to be figuring out like
what the heck I'm doing with all the
keys saving this data. It's kind of a
bit of mess.
See, we can't load them twice either,
right?
We're currently fixing up constellation,
which is our local dashboard for
experiments. Whoops.
It looks a lot cooler when you have more
data loaded into it. It's super fast.
It's all in C. It'll be web compatible.
Uh we're doing this while we have some
experiments running in the background on
mazes. So it's basically a combination
of work on cleaning up stuff for release
our tools and stuff uh while we're
running experiments and then every so
often figure out if the experiments make
sense so we actually have um something
working and learning correctly.
Let's figure this out.
We need the sweep keys, don't we?
I'm thinking here like, yeah, I could
technically just put all the load the
loading into C and it would be easier,
but the problem is I don't want the poor
data file to be massive,
right? Because I want the poor data file
to be loadable on web.
it needs the freaking sweep distribution
is the annoying bit.
Not having specific metrics also sucks.
Hey, Disciple.
Not a big fan of this actually from the
more I'm looking at it. Not a big fan of
all
cuz if you sweep an N metric, right,
then you don't have it.
this is data for one though, isn't it?
This is data for one.
Puffer is the uh the fastest RL around.
We do small model, non- language model,
RL,
pretty much everything that's not a
language model.
Okay.
Load in data set. Right.
Wait, we can totally just do this, can't
we?
Yeah. Why am I being such a dingus here?
Like, these don't have to be the same
per they don't have to be the same
across Ms. They just need to be the same
per M.
Yeah, man. That's just a curriculum
thing.
Like I don't know if it's going to be
better to just enneal over training or
to have it be adaptive.
But like basically it's going to have to
be the simplest curriculum method we can
come up with. So we just leave ourselves
the fewest places to screw stuff up. you
know, if we can do it as like um
know one additional Npiper for instance
for sweeping,
you know, like maybe an adaptive range
or something.
It's a little slow at the moment. I
think the policies can definitely get
better, but that's definitely uh that's
definitely getting somewhere.
It's also going to have to be like the
number of agents and stuff like that.
I'd say that that is quite good progress
though for the uh the time being. Oh,
yeah. It is technically it's a Thursday,
isn't it?
Um, I can look at this with you later
today, but I definitely need some time
to work on for release so we can put in
a little bit of a session later. I'm
trying to clean up constellation so that
we can actually get it. I basically want
to have it so that you can actually have
the like load data into it, click data,
copy hypers back over so we can stop
being so reliant on wi and stop screwing
up runs for it. I also caught another
major bug in the training earlier today
that was like messing up our results on
harder ends. So, I'm re sweeping that to
see. It's quite difficult though. Like
there's a lot of jank.
That's kind of the uh the current stuff.
Need to work on other things. Another
day is possible. Yeah, that's actually
even better, man.
I'll have some time tomorrow. I'll have
some time maybe Saturday
be good.
currently an EDA. Can I help on it? I
don't know what EDA is.
It's pretty good. I'm going to have some
more time as well over the next several
days to get some stuff done. Um I really
want at least I'm going to see if I can
get Constellation to be pretty stable
since I've got like a few days in which
I'm going to mostly be waiting on
experiments and stuff. Um
constellation shouldn't be that hard to
like finish finish
and then
uh and then it's mostly going to come
down to correct training and clean
clean code cleaned up code
Oh, no. We can't cuz we need it there.
That's fine. I'm about to solve this
now.
I think we just go for the first back,
right?
I don't even like to have this logic in
here, though.
We need it for the stupid end pram too
though.
Let's try just doing the simple thing,
man.
not logging agent steps.
Wait log or log
append logs
the minus end there.
Okay, cuz I logged this data like a
dummy.
Weird.
student freshman.
It's a good place to learn.
If you're a freshman,
um I highly recommend my programming and
ML article.
Like if you actually read this every so
often and really try to understand why
I've written what I've written here,
this will help you out a lot. This is my
single highest rated piece of content.
Um, and it's been endorsed by some
pretty freaking cool people.
So,
this is like the best I can possibly
give you.
To be honest, I probably wouldn't have
um I probably wouldn't have known to
take my own advice even if I told myself
back then, but it would have saved me
thousands of
tips for aspiring AI in the mail. I just
linked you, man.
Read that. Understand it.
learn to write a men.
All right.
Why are we just straight not logging
hypers, man?
Okay. I mean, I've got to just fix the
way I'm logging [ __ ] cuz this makes no
bloody sense.
Uh, also we can just make this.
This will go here and this will go here.
I actually just need this tab, don't I?
That'll be better.
we shouldn't need to touch data at all.
It should literally just be
logs
updated.
This is completely wrong.
Got this here.
Sweep knot. Next.
Why the [ __ ] is this not
all right? Come on. prospering.
This is good. It's all good.
Clarity
filter to burrito.
It's good.
So
just Turn.
Okay,
good.
We're getting somewhere.
Oops.
Here's the restroom and grab some more
tea. We're making progress. This is
going to be a little bit slow,
but no worries. Um, it's very, very
important we have this right and that we
end up like simplifying this as much as
possible,
you know? I mean, like the really more I
see like the type of how I feel doing
this work versus how I feel with the LLM
crap.
Um
the clarity that you give up with the
language models is really bad. Like I
can essentially now see the problem. I
see where all the complexities are. I'm
starting to see, okay, I'm going to be
able to simplify this, this, and this.
Like,
yeah, it's just very different.
I missed this.
And this is super slow, but like I still
missed this.
Okay, I will be back. Give me a minute.
Love how big your mug is. Thank you. You
can also optimize um samples if you
want. There's both. But I honestly I
think that pure sample efficiency
optimization is one of the things that
killed the field. I have multiple
articles about this. And uh not a single
one of my clients has been like, "Oh no,
your deliverable works so well, but you
had to train on 500 million samples."
They're just like, "Cool, it trains in
two minutes."
Doing this without claw. Yes, this is
without claw here. Um, the constellation
script is entirely without the big heavy
models. I have a really, really stupid
single line autocomplete that's like not
much better than LSP.
So, I will be right back.
I hate that we even have to have the
script in Python, but let's just have
this for now.
new bit.
Let me check.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is good progress, man.
This is good progress.
Yeah, that's good progress.
This approach is a good call. Yeah, I
think this actually like unblocks us. We
can definitely make some good progress
on this.
This thing is going to need
quite a bit different.
Okay,
we do actually have our points.
I only see one point here though.
One point.
I mean, I see one point,
but there should be three.
should be three.
This is down here.
I'm going have to fix all this.
Um, let's get ourselves some more points
real quick.
few more points really. That's all we
need.
and we can start on some other stuff.
And we're not letting that super long
one go.
Interesting.
Let's figure out why the points aren't
rendering in the way we should expect.
Yeah, this menu is not.
The fact it can draw off screen is bad.
There's no way around it.
You can click it here.
Oh, there it is. It's down there. You
see
it's just super low.
And then if we have up time,
it's 5 seconds.
Oh, it is there. It's just really small.
Okay, it's here.
Cool.
nothing is here. Suddenly
that log transform maybe
So not visible on top of this.
Oh, it's getting drawn underneath.
That's why
plot GL
figure two.
Maybe it's just the transparencies.
Okay.
It's not a good deal for now.
next biggest problem is going to be the
scaling.
Look how much code we have. We have 1500
lines of code here.
Wouldn't the easiest thing just be to
add
a scale option for logic?
would fail, wouldn't it?
Maybe here wouldn't.
Yeah, I see what I did to mess
everything up here. It's not that bad to
fix this, though.
Can I do it this way?
Yeah. I'm not going to do it this way.
sample size affects training speed.
Any articles relative string sizing
steps
sample size affect the training speed
up.
What do you mean sample size?
Like what happens if we use our library
with very few samples
or like
you break the algorithm is what happens
on policy. RL just doesn't work when you
crank up number of samples massively. I
did publish one article where I
basically I found a mathematical reason
why you're kind of just screwed trying
to make other classes of methods fast
and wall clock.
So unless you have you pretty much need
to bridge the great gap between um the
long advantage bootstrap that you can do
with onpaul and the really bad bootstrap
that you have to do with offpaul.
I guess the closest thing to what you're
asking about, which is like why I'm not
that concerned about this type of stuff
anymore. I thought a lot about like, oh,
how do we get the sample efficiency this
and that for a while?
Um,
and then I figured this out. Let me find
it.
This, it's a pretty niche one. But um
but if you read this,
it pretty much just comes down to onpaul
having access to a dramatically more
powerful bootstrap
to the point I don't even think it's
worth really looking at off Paul
anymore.
I think this is going to be a little bit
of a mess.
That's okay. I got time. I can clean
this today.
Just have to make experiments are
working. Oh yeah. See, this is actually
worthwhile. We're actually getting like
reasonable stuff now.
Yeah. Yeah, we're getting reasonable
stuff. This is still not amazing, right?
We're not getting like solves. Still way
worse than um the Rio, which is bad, but
I really hope it's not just like, uh oh,
we need RMS form or some [ __ ]
I did just test that on breakout. That
would that was really bad.
We have options though. We've got like
several apps here.
Let's say
Okay,
it's better.
Good.
No.
Do you need to even have the text
anywhere?
to access scale collection.
This right.
Okay. You accidentally click this quite
often, but it's fine.
Fix that.
The other thing that we could do would
be
pointer.
That's so jank though, isn't it?
Very, very jank.
Only 84 runs.
Okay, this is concerning, but it is
getting fast like mediocre sauce,
you know.
Okay, I guess we'll just wait on this.
We'll see.
That is concerning though.
I kind of see what I was doing with the
original though.
this right
need
This approach would be no approach
more code direction.
I think I like that.
All right. I think um I have an idea
with this
how we're going to do this clean. So
we'll clean this up. Right back in
Israel from
There's no check box anymore. I think it
it changes the way I want to do it.
Okay. What happens if we do it this way?
Right.
Holy
active
What's this?
Why is it shows active?
It's just on active
option select and star active.
Oh, star active. I say
Oh, it's the warnings, you dummy.
Okay, it's in the warnings.
Okay. So now you have
uh now we have the
actual problem that we want to have
which is that positioning of this which
is easier.
Drop down checkbox. This is supposed to
be
drop down width.
And then this double click thing is
really annoying,
I think we can actually clean it up from
here, right?
That's no rapper is best rapper.
This is better now.
this better or worse,
honestly,
except I broke it for sure.
Let's see what's wrong with
This be this is four
two.
There we go.
Then
there's the log color.
What's this supposed to be?
Long color.
Do we drop down checkbox?
Looks like C++.
What on earth looks like C++ in here?
This is about as C as it gets.
C C style C++. This is not even C++.
This is C.
I don't even know what the heck this is
supposed to have on um
and hyper options.
Am I done? What did I
Oh, I see. because it's the color on.
Yes. Cool.
Hyper options.
And then the color scale rect is going
to be
this is not the toggle width.
This is
Wait, settings height.
Uh, I see
like this. It's just a square.
And then we do like this.
Uh five times drop down with
and then no not that
we check box
just log color.
Generating C.
No, this is just C.
There's no template. There's nothing.
It's just great C.
Okay. So, now we have this. We got to
play with the leg the widths of these a
little bit.
Um,
let's see what we accomplished by that.
Not too much, honestly.
I mean, honestly, the only thing that's
annoying here is the
like this poke wouldn't even be bad
except for the uh the rectangle math,
right?
And some of the names.
So yeah, I think we just fix up the like
we'll assume we're just going to fix up
the names instead of making a um
a mess of this and trying to like wrap
it more.
Like this would actually be reasonably
short I would think, right?
Yeah. This is not going to help us
though, is it?
No, it will actually cuz the reason we
were doing this is cuz we needed to
change the log box. So, let's just do
this for fig two.
We'll just do this for fig two and we'll
be uh we'll be set up pretty nicely.
Yeah. See, this is like
I don't like that this is autofill.
If it's autofill, it feels like it
literally should be um it should be
easier to separate this, but I can't see
a good way to do that that I don't hate
immediately.
But this is twice the length that it
will be will be just by cleaning up the
names. Right?
And then color.
Let's I'd be surprised if this even gets
it.
This one's not that bad, though. It's
just over there.
So all we have to do is
Oh, it just did um hang on.
Drop down with
toggle width.
So this is supposed to be
toggle width
toggle width.
Uh this is three and two
and then this is
four and two.
Yeah,
there we go.
Okay. So, that's actually not terrible.
Now, we have to do the coloring.
Wouldn't live without templates. I don't
think I can live with templates. Those
things are awful.
Like templates are such cancer. You
start adding them to one thing and it's
everything becomes freaking templated.
All right.
So now the reason we were doing this was
originally just so we could do
X index. Yes, this
Xcale idx.
We're just going to do
in
scale.
So we can just replace this
with x.
We can replace this with X scale for
now.
We're going to just treat this in like a
bowl for now.
I don't know. Templates just complicate
the crap out of everything.
Awful, awful compiler errors.
They like infest code very quickly.
It's kind of the same thing as like
Amazing. Awful. Awful.
Where's the do check box?
Oh,
it does. Yeah, that's getting
Oh, it does. Yeah, that's getting removed anyways,
removed anyways,
so that's easy.
Not bad. All right.
This got messed up.
So, we have
the width is wrong.
No, doesn't look like it.
What I give this a
okay.
Not bad, right?
We got our stuff.
UI works
fine.
So,
we got a couple different things we got
to do with this.
Hey Star, like already in what you've
said, you've got this gigantic track of
the abstractions and stuff. I just don't
want any of it. Like in what I've been
working on lately, I just want to have
the fewest number of things possible.
Okay.
So, I guess now it's just a matter of
let's see where do we use this? So, we
do
we use it in the m and maxes here.
Oh, that's easy, right?
We just swap this for a oneliner.
Oh, and it's not even that bad, is it?
Does this just scale?
Oh, I see what you mean.
Um,
yeah,
I've gone through like several different
versions of different precision support
and like
they all kind of suck to be honest with
you.
Like you can't just go operator opening
like you can't just go doing that ei
because like you're writing kernels
here.
You actually need to know the freaking d
types
and then like bloat doesn't work the
same. Like it's not the same. It's just
like a shorter whatever.
I mean the good news is most of the
element wise kernels like they're not
actually using a bunch of different
precisions. They're just using a bunch
of precisions for the input and output
and then all the intermediate calcs are
always the same.
We came up with a decent enough way of
handling it. I think actually what we do
now in puffer is we do stat compilation.
So um we only compile for a specific
precision and our compilation is fast.
So you don't need the templates because
the templates let you give um get
multiple precisions at compile time. We
just have one precision. It's just like
one very very simple oneline macro.
Yeah, I'm happier with this.
Like if you think about it, you don't
actually really need to support multiple
precisions uh in a single run.
You pretty much are always just going to
use Vflat and if stuff explodes, you're
going to try FP32.
right. So, we got
linear.
Okay.
Linear log.
Then let's go add
There.
All right. Now we got log
log linear
Yeah, it is working cool. Now we will
have to change a couple of things
but that's pretty much what we wanted.
That will instantly fix our export
problem, won't it?
Actually, we can check.
score, per learning rate, you can see
gamma, lambda, all these params are now
reasonable. We're no longer applying
norms to the params themselves.
We're just applying params to the scale.
What time is it? I think it's time for
more tea.
Okay. Yeah. Um I'll be right back. I'm
going to grab more cake and then we will
We'll continue on the refactor. I got I
really want to figure out like what I'm
going to do with the UI finally.
Then I'll just clean it up a lot. And
then of course there's all of the like
data prep-processing and stuff.
But I'll be back. We got lots of time.
right.
So,
the UI problem, right?
Let's just take a look at the amount of
stuff that we have in this thing. So
the actual main function itself I think
is most of the program.
Yeah.
A Dota thingy. Oh man, that's like a
long time ago.
Yeah. We've kind of um
RL is a totally different field now with
the stuff we've come up with.
I mean we have like
10 plus milst step per second training
15 mil in some cases
new architectures hyper prim new
environments algorithmic progress
so much stuff was like a year and a half
ago right
okay
It's just a whole big mass of code, huh?
Is what it is?
18ish months. Yeah, I've been working.
Um,
okay. So, this screen, this
constellation overlay that we're going
to ignore that for now.
Texture rack.
I mean, looking at this, the UI is not
like
it's not even like the UI is a ton of
code compared to this. It's just like a
big block of procedural code is what it
is.
I'm actually not too annoyed with this
and then these just use the roll boxes.
Okay.
So, we need some data for these
we need some data for these so we can
start testing stuff. The copy feature I
think is not fully done.
There's some small improvements and then
I think the main thing is not copying.
Don't think we copy all the MSP specific
params yet. Those are important.
So, we can go look at that.
How's this doing?
You know, this is weird because
like we've got all these really short
runs that do well,
but it's like it's not letting it keep
training better for longer.
we got 25 runs
and
but they cap.
They actually really hard, don't they?
I'm going to let this go for a little
bit longer. just to see if we break
through this plateau at all. Um,
and while I still work on constellation,
but we're going to get back to this a
little bit today.
So,
Huh.
Interesting. So, they just get
registered in whatever order.
It's cool.
What if we just disable?
I know what we can do.
We'll just do this. We'll just disable
um burrito.
six points.
It's fine. And then we will copy the all
CAD into
rebuild
six data points.
Six data points, but they're all down
here.
Not too usable.
Uh, I guess we can do gamma.
There's one down here.
I think they're just like super low or
whatever.
Okay. And then if I do
So, we got linear scale.
We got linear scale.
These are very similar
logic scale which is not what we want.
Okay. So we take um gamma
budget scale
really should eat something soon. Wasn't
live for what, 5 and a half hours?
Not too bad yet.
That's no good.
Gamma logic scale.
Okay. So, you don't want to scale the
values. You want to scale
Well, that doesn't make any sense at
all, does it?
Yeah.
Linear scale.
Is this even what we're trying to do?
Like
let's do this.
Yeah,
Come on, just think. This is so simple.
I just don't understand how I'm using
this with the problem, right?
Oh, this is why, right?
Yeah.
FXF
not am I hard like not inputting math?
No, I am.
Oh, is it just XP? That's just X back
dummy.
Nice fish. Thank you.
We do enjoy our pup around here.
we got um score on log scale.
This is giving us the log. That's not
what we want. Logit
logit is not going to work obviously
because
Gamma
kind of works in gamma.
Wait, this doesn't work. Oh, cuz it's X.
X 10.
there. That gives us nice scaling,
right?
Gamma on here.
cuz log scale
we'll put everything up here.
Linear
logic spreads them out a bunch.
That's better.
Let's try uh let me try it this way.
If I just put this gamma
and I put this on logic scale.
Yeah.
Might want more digits, but this is
good.
This is good.
I like this.
draw text. Oh, but now we actually have
to make it line up. Ha.
2 px.
We have a power f in here.
We do not have a power function.
Is it still correct?
Let's see if it's still correct.
Let's take this to gamma.
Okay. So this one's going to be like
gamma 97ish.
And then if I put this in logic
that looks good.
Okay.
This is usable
or getting usable quite quickly
like that.
So the cool thing here, right, is I can
right click this this point and this is
the nice new feature.
You can paste everything. It just copies
to clipboard.
So
we want to group these
Are we built?
I got it.
right. Is this good?
Uh, no. We have to do right.
What do you find like index of
char stars black? Wait char
SL
minus prefix.
Oh, this is going to be it.
Boom. Look at that.
Look at that.
That's lovely.
And then all we have to do
is um
I don't like that loop, but that's fine
for now. I think that gets it right.
Look at that.
So we get
uh almost
for um let's do
suffix
Wait, what?
Format.
What?
Oh, no. It's not here.
It's this.
It's just this um
like this maybe. Right.
Huh.
That's not good.
buffer
preix length.
Oh, it's missing the slash.
two.
String processing in C is one of the
actually kind of rough things.
dude. What is wrong with me? Why can't I
do this?
Isn't it just this like
where's it plus one?
I don't think so.
Wait. SN print. What does this actually
return?
If n had been sufficiently large.
Okay,
that's annoying.
Look at that.
Boom.
Oh, look at that
beauty.
We might have to change it to a double,
but for now it's good.
All right. So, we're missing just end
params now, right?
like in the sense that it's not copying
um
I mean that's going to be like the best
feature ever honestly just being able to
copy the damn hypers that you want from
the plot
and also it'll be fully deterministic.
So that's pretty cool, right? So you'll
literally be able to just go repro your
exact experiment at least if you're on
the same machine that you ran the
original.
You know, it is uh it's only
determinative per like architecture or
whatever. That's a limitation.
right, I'm sure might be back in a
minute and then we'll figure out that
Trump
All right.
So, the next little thing I want to
figure out is
See if we can get our end param showing
up in the sweeps. That's not good that
it's not copying those
does it get saved?
Let's see if it gets saved.
Hey, just put a breakout a break point.
There we go. Data
train blah trains like this,
right?
Lots of crap.
right? So it needs to also have the end
matrix. Right.
Well, hang on.
Environment slash.
This one we can do, can't we?
As long as we don't introduce more.
So we basically we have to think of like
there's a trade-off here between this
thing being a little bit more flexible
and then this thing having stronger
checking on the fields that we know be
there.
I think we can just assert fail on um a
file, right?
Is it required for OBS?
Uh, it's not required, but it's strongly
recommended.
Oh, but you don't have to like you don't
have to return them that way. Like,
yeah, it's fine if you have one hot. You
can return one hot. It's just if you
return one hot, then um you're going to
need a custom encoder, right?
You're not going to want the default
encoder.
Very small one hots, it's usually better
to just do in the end because it makes
it easier. uh bigger one hots like you
burn too much bandwidth on so you don't
do it
set of five playing cards
5 * 13 you could do either way for that
one
if you wanted to make that really easy
if it's only if the only thing well
you're not going to just observe a set
of five playing cards though right
you're going to observe other people's
Because if you're just observing five, I
would do the one hot the end. But if
it's more than that, you're probably
going to want to do it in the encoder.
Discard pile of sorts.
Okay.
I don't know what game you're doing
then.
This freaking Kha may have [ __ ]
here.
Okay, let's get to the keys.
This does get us environment keys.
Python.
Oops. No, don't do that. That'd be very
bad. Holy, that would have been awful.
Okay, I actually want to make a commit
just so I don't do that by mistake being
tired.
Okay,
let's do this
Yeah. No, we don't see all the new
metrics.
Yeah, here it is.
This filter off, right?
Oh,
heat buffer. Okay.
Oh, okay.
So, this is probably massive.
Hey, look at that, though. That does get
everything.
Maybe there's some stuff we want to
prune out,
but that got absolutely everything.
And then this environment at the end,
this uh this tag,
that's fine.
That's pretty good.
That's pretty freaking good.
Boom.
And you just can't see everything in the
UI.
We probably should like filter some
stuff from the logs.
I think that's like enough for us to
start using this thing ourselves as
well.
All right. What is going on with this?
Like
29 experiments
and they're all hard capping
So grid gets passed.
It's total agents.
Max size map size
to fix issue. Which issue? I fixed a few
issues.
What's the latest? What are you working
on? Well, we just got constellation
cleaned up a little bit. So, this is our
dashboard that we have that we can load
data into. And I now have it. So, if you
right click on any of the points, you
get this little preview. But more
importantly,
I can now paste it. Copies all the
hypers to your clipboard. So, it's
really, really good for reproducing
runs.
So, that was the one of the main
features I really wanted to have with
this. Now, constellation doesn't look
super good yet because it's like we
don't have anything like any of the
actual data loaded into it. Um, that's
definitely going to be part of it. I'm
doing this kind of in parallel though as
I'm running other experiments. It's
3:30. I'm thinking it makes sense to
spend a little bit of time looking at
our our results on grid. Maybe
I believe grid has the old format as
well. So, we're going to have to copy
params over manually
one more time.
It looks super stable.
Okay.
hidden size
three layers.
Oh, it looks way cooler when you have
data loaded into it. You'll see.
Numb buffer num threads. Total agents is
2048.
Wand restrictive. Yeah, it's really
freaking slow is the problem. Like
it's so so slow.
I also wanted something that I could
just embed in our website cleanly and
have it be super clean. Uh so like this
whole dashboard, we're going to be able
to preload all our experiment data from
40 into it and just stick it on the
site. It'll be very nice.
Do you have ch jacks and TPU? Um, I
honestly don't even want to look at
Jacks. I've gone and benchmarked it.
It's not faster. the code is awful
and it provides literally no way to even
make your code any faster because like
it's too high level.
So that thing that whole thing is just
screwed.
Um
if we get a TPU back end in the future,
it'll either be via like PyTorch XLA
support for our like our fallbacks or
for using Tiny uh for the pure Python
mode. But our focus at the moment is
going to be on the raw CUDA back end
which is just so so much faster and
really lets us like actually think about
stuff at the level we need to be which
is much lower level than what torch
gives Okay.
Palace.
I don't think it is.
Yeah, dude. This is not Cuda. This is
[ __ ] Python.
This is like Triton maybe, but this is
not a permit.
I'm sorry. I've gotten just so so sick
of it the last several weeks cuz like
the number of hours I've wasted because
of the constraints that these stupid
highle frameworks place on you like they
take you so far away from the hardware
like you think that you can do this but
actually you can do this it's just that
the hardware is like you have this big
framework between you and the hardware
that's very restrictive and it really
doesn't give you any benefit either like
a lot of the CUDA is now going to just
be simpler
I think this does have the fixing,
right?
Let's see if this lags too bad.
Oops.
Maybe I should be a little bit more
specific just so you can see why this is
so bad.
>> Cool. Do you notice something
interesting here? No for loops.
No for loops. No for loops. No for loop.
Cool. No for loops.
So you have to think entirely in array
operations.
And if your stuff doesn't fit an array
operation, too bad.
I can just write C through the C. I have
access to so so much more.
We're going to let this run locally for
a bit.
See if this repro
lags my camera a little bit, but
hopefully mic is still good.
Audio should be separate. Yeah.
was the original.
See, the original gets 93.
We're stuck low
to figure out what's wrong.
This having a hard cap is suspicious to
me.
Usually there's nothing wrong with the
end when you get like all the runs hard
cap like that.
double free or corruption out.
Well, we didn't submit this patch.
That's fine.
to save the model though.
Oh, come on.
Excuse me.
Vision range is five.
Yeah, we do.
All right. So, we're um
we got some stuff to go check,
but we are on to experimental work here.
We notice that we can train some stuff.
There's this big gap in performance.
chicken sandwich. I really don't
recommend McDonald's to anybody.
Um, I will be right back. Let me grab
more tea and then we will figure this
out. I have some ideas. I have some
ideas in this.
let me get me a second to do one thing
on the side here
All right,
we begin the search.
First candidate.
Where's the state?
Where state get used here?
graph zero
MB state
on the trans stream. I bet. Yeah, this
could be this could definitely do it,
right?
Puff zero.
Let's just do puff zero on that. Right.
right. Well, this is going to lag, but
we're going to chill here for a bit.
See if this makes a difference.
It could.
Very well. Could
Dude, obviously I've got like 10 of
them.
This didn't work, which is weird.
I think this is what we're doing wrong.
eval.
Yeah, we zero states.
We zero our states.
I don't know if it is Bbug, but it's a
bug.
Okay,
that's a new set of experiments
that is like an actually reasonable
candidate for stuff being wrong,
I would say.
When will we get humanoid robots
cleaning my house? That's like the least
interesting possible application of RL
in my mind.
realistic answer to that is you probably
pretty soon there'll be some companies
where you can pay somebody uh from the
Philippines to like tea op a robot to do
chores or whatever but that's like the
least interesting possible application
in my mind.
We figured out
one candidate at least.
Most efficient robot design is not going
to be humanoid. You think
lo and behold, the specialized robots
that are 10,000 times faster be way
better than having like robot sort
package.
I definitely rebuilt, right?
Yes, I definitely rebuilt.
Yes. Okay. I definitely did this
correctly.
I don't want some dude checking out my
house remotely. Well, if you want a dude
hang checking out your house in person,
you can hire a housekeeper nowadays.
If you have a well-paying job, it's very
affordable. I highly recommend it.
Oh, there we go.
Cool.
Why is that mug so large?
Because I drink a lot of tape.
And at least this way I have to get up
every hour or so instead of every like
20 minutes.
Okay, so we have that running.
What else is there to do in the
meantime?
Yeah, maybe let's do something local.
Let's do some local stuff.
I just want like a really quick end that
we can run a bunch of uh local
experiments on for constellation.
most exciting Rale projects one should
check out besides my own.
If you'd asked me a few years ago, I'd
have a bunch of answers for you, but
like
pretty much all the ones that I think
are exciting were done many years ago at
this point and they're all in my guide.
Is there anything else? I guess like
also in the Puffer Discord, we got
contributors building fulls,
but they're kind of all in the Puffer
ecosystem at this point.
Like there's honestly not that much
stuff I'm excited about outside of
Puffer, which is sad.
Like there used to be a bunch of cool
stuff in the field, but now mostly like
not really
When Starcraft and Dota ender,
I built a mini mobile. It could be built
out more.
Um,
honestly, I've been so focused on like
the core infert and stuff. We have a lot
of environments from contributors we can
use at this point. Uh, I think that if I
do build another like really big
environment, it'll probably be something
nutty. Like I'll probably see if I can
just do a direct port of Runescape to
see.
I still don't know how I want to go
about that though because like I could
technically just go grab private server
code,
you know, that's already out there. Um,
it would be really cool to do something
with actual like official Jagex Four.
They don't have a microtransactions in
old school.
They deleted a whole bunch of them from
RS3 apparently recently.
Oh yeah, speaking of old school, while
we wait for a few of these to run,
we got the update on the pure 97
strength.
And that goes back to the side monitor.
Not too good these um options we got
here, huh?
Nothing good here yet either.
This is brand new though.
Not finding much on Pong at all, huh?
Kind of jank.
Okay, this is some data. It's just not
very good data yet.
I just wanted like some reasonable runs.
Is it too much to ask?
uptime
agent steps.
Cool.
And then we can do all.
We can do all like this.
Um,
and now this is a mess, you see, because
we are on four. But if we go to Perf,
they actually fit nicely on the same
graph.
And then look, we have end name, this is
breakout, this is long.
If I can look at like stuff like here,
gamma.
Gamma was the test we wanted, right?
Train SL gamma. Oh, no. But it's like
the scale is weird. Linear scale is
really bad. What about logic scale? Oh,
look. Logic scale is good. Yay. Right.
Not bad overall.
Some small bugs
How does it know what should show up
here?
Does it only show hypers?
It only shows hypers.
I don't know if that's a huge deal
though to be honest.
We might just separate some pars
different spots.
I'm way more concerned about the overall
training than I am anything else at this
point.
All right. Nothing here.
What's this?
We'll see if any of those actually are
pass for our stuff.
All right. Um,
the problem is that like I can kind of
just infinitely sit on this frame and
wonder if I got the fix correct.
Right.
I guess here what are the core what are
the key possibilities? Right.
possibilities are there's a bug in the
training code. Um,
second possibility is
the architecture is not as good as I
thought it was
and it needs a norm.
The problem is that one's actually kind
of terrifying.
I think that one is terrifying enough.
It's worth spending a little bit of time
investigating
because if that happens, we're just
screwed, right?
We're not that screwed. Like we'll lose
some perf on the norm though.
It makes the architecture way way less
appealing.
All right, let's try this. Here's what
we're going to do.
We've already confirmed this repro,
right?
So, here's what we're going to do.
We're going to run the original
hypers
with all the new fixes.
And we're going to see if this is stable
because I do remember these being like
the magic freaking hypers. This
10.4
agents.
The problem is that this doesn't work at
all. It also doesn't tell us much,
right?
I just like hyperp transfer
What does KDUNN give us
actually?
This looks good.
Is there any reason for me to not just
be using KDUNM for these? I think that's
what I should be doing, right?
It looks like a pretty nice low-level
API.
Interesting.
82.
Let's go to four layers.
Oh, it's old.
It's open source, isn't it?
We could maybe pull it right out.
Okay, this is giving me stuff to think
about for sure.
This is all the torch is doing, right?
It's calling coding in to the source.
use the restroom real quick and then um
what time is it? It's only 4:40. Got a
little bit more time. We're going to
think about this a little bit. We're
going to think about this a little bit.
Um and we will go from there.
I'll kind of go through my thoughts a
little bit on why I'm doing all this
stuff as well. Be right back.
All right. So,
let's um let's talk a little bit about
what's going on here, right?
A few things.
So, I fixed a couple of bugs today. Um I
fixed important lane, a bug with the way
that we were updating stale advantage
estimates.
And I fixed a bug with initialization
where uh
basically the min state wasn't getting
zeroed consistently
before that the original hyperparameters
did not work at all. All right. So the
original hyperparameters for popper 3
did not work at all. Now I know that for
most of our environments uh when we have
just like a pretty simple implementation
of the architecture in torch the
hyperparameters actually transferred
pretty well. So this is kind of weird
right like they should actually be at
least reasonably transferable
after fixing everything though after
fixing the zeros and stuff. Now the
default hypers are at least pretty good.
In fact this is better than any of the
nets I've seen before. See if this has
found anything good.
Now, this has not found anything amazing
yet, but we actually did find like a 082
or whatever. So, that's pretty nice.
Now, that's still pretty far off in perf
from the old thing.
So,
uh the possibilities here are either
that this just needs to be aggressively
re-swept. I remember in this in
particular, this environment needing
quite a bit of attention to detail with
the hyperparameter tuning.
The thing I'm worried about
is that this architecture is a bit
weaker because we don't have the norms
in it. So I tested that this thing could
do uh exactly the same on neural MMO 3
as LSTM with the same hypers
with norms.
The problem is that the norms were
really slow.
So then instead I came up with this
fancy gating mechanism.
to try out instead.
And I tested that it was about the same
on breakout, but I probably didn't give
it enough like reasonable testing to see
if it's actually good on harder
problems.
So, I think that the biggest biggest
risk at the moment is that we have like
a two week gate or whatever
uh in min. That's kind of a problem.
I have no idea if this is the case.
We're running here just a slightly
deeper net to see if it does any better.
So, if there's any lift from having a
few more parameters, but it gets stuck
around 82,
which is not that good um not that good
performance I'd say for this network.
I don't have a great solution to this.
Uh I am seeing though that there is an
RMS norm Actually, is there RMS form or
just layer norm?
Hopefully there's RMS
RMS.
Okay, it has ars. Good.
So, what I can probably do
tonight,
I'll probably do this off stream after
dinner,
um, because it's just going to be a
bunch of claud [ __ ] is just figure out
the KUDNN backend API. And we just add a
path into our code so that we do a uh an
RMS norm on the output. And we basically
just see if that fixes our problems.
And if it does essentially, that means I
probably screwed up with my architecture
design
and we're going to have to figure some
stuff out. Now, this is a deeper network
and it's actually doing a little bit
worse.
And I do remember this being very
sensitive to hypers.
So I'm not completely sure,
right? I'm not completely sure
whether it is uh one or the other. Here
we do have these hypers though as being
quite good. So I will commit these
And then after dinner, I suppose I'll do
some stuff on.
That'll be decent.
That'll be messy, but we'll have to do
that.
that give us conclusive
let's say conclusive evidence one way or
the other.
you basically just got to give him a
docker, right?
You basically have to give people a
freaking docker
of the game sim of the game. Wait, what?
What?
They have some good stuff in here
though.
that's another good question. Which of
these are open source and which of these
aren't
Okay.
I mean, this is what you sort of expect.
sweep is not doing great. But then
again, it's also just like
quite a lot. Let me get stuff committed.
Let's get some stuff committed for sure.
crucial.
No. Okay.
Yeah, I think that the next the next
main thing is going to be
to try to get the network to repro
be very stupid and vibe.
Let me go check something real quick.
Just check on dinner plans.
All right. So, yeah, I'm going to go
grab dinner 15
full full platformer games. So,
the problem is not platformer. Yes,
Metroid Vania is much harder than
platformer.
the back the backtracking is like very
very much human intuition and the like.
Um
it's very hard to learn that from the
game itself.
If you just strip out all the graphics
like
essentially I could make one a onetoone
replica of the difficult part of that
game if you don't understand the visuals
and the graphics. So, if you're like an
untrained agent and then you'd be able
to see why it's a ludicrously difficult
exploration problem to do that. Um, that
said, I might have a way to do this in
the future,
but like I think specifically the thing
of, oh, here's a shortcut I can't get
past. I'm going to come back later when
I have something that looks like it'll
help me pass that shortcut. That's
really tough. Uh, and if you don't have
that intuition, you basically can't play
the games.
So, that's the tough thing.
Long form, more linear games though.
Absolutely.
visual and dialogue.
Yeah. So I mean the thing is that you
will get the visual and dialogue that
will come from uh VLMs but then the way
to then use that to direct an RL agent
without it being just incredibly slow is
still unclear.
But that's honestly not the main problem
I'm hung up on.
There should be one, right?
Yeah, it's there.
Low level C API. Good. I want CPI.
Give me CAPI.
actually cudn.
Let's
see. Is this good? It's actually longer,
funny enough, to use it than the knot.
Uh, this needs the the path from torch.
Yeah, that's just the path from torque.
Did it forget that it's bundled with
torch?
I think I can use this to at least
debug.
Um,
you can probably use this to at least
debug.
backend descriptors make tensor
I say
make tensor
including backend descript
Make
It's a pointer to an opaque strct,
so you can't use it.
cuz it's opaque, right? Yeah, it's
opaque.
Damn.
So, that means we shouldn't use this
uh for our like native stuff, but that's
okay.
Do I need to understand how a CPU works
for RL? I mean, low level is definitely
going to help.
you know we use um depending on the
version multi-threading or
multipprocessing for
uh distributing environments
there's also there is cudas of course
cudas all parallelism and then there's
cuda stream level parallelism for
rollouts at the moment
concurrency a little bit not as much we
kind of just do that ourselves via
threading we don't use like um
I don't know what the hell the j it's
not the javascript style of
Um,
but knowing low level helps a lot,
but I I like I say that when the vast
majority of RL people don't understand a
damn thing about that, but like that's
kind of why I'm being able to do all the
stuff that I can, right?
Um,
I see.
Great descriptor.
What am I trying to fix? I'm not trying
to fix anything at the moment. I'm
actually I'm playing around with KudnM.
Well, I guess the thing I'm trying to
fix, I suppose, is uh the models are not
performing as well as
the 30 models.
And I verified that the new model
architecture works well with layered
warm, but I made a change to the gating
mechanism that I don't think I tested
well enough. And that's kind of the last
thing that I could think of for why our
current uh setup would not be working as
well.
So, I'm basically playing around with
that.
So, I am going to be heading to dinner
in just a few moments.
I think that this is mostly gonna
because this is like boring flaw stuff
because I'm not familiar with QDNM. So,
this is basically going to be me
figuring out the API because like look
at this. It's a very
it's not the fact that it's a C API. I
actually really like a C API. The fact
that it's an opaque CAPI
makes it kind of rough.
But um what we were going to do is first
of all we need QDN anyways because we
have networks that need comps and this
is the fast comp that you use. Uh but
also it has an RMS norm and that comp is
a nightmare to implement manually.
So, we're going to see if we can use
this to test out the networks tonight
and then I'll be back to report in the
morning to see how that's gone.
I think I am going to call it just about
now though. Um, I will be back. I might
stream some later tonight, but I'll
probably just get back on stream in the
morning. I should get a little bit of
exercise tomorrow, too. I haven't run
this week. I've only lifted. Um, so
we'll see about that. But for folks
watching, thank you for tuning in live
for eight and a half hours almost here.
Um,
if you'd like to support my work for
absolutely free, just star the buffer on
GitHub. Helps me out a lot. All open
source RL join Discord to get involved.
And I have to fix this link, but it's
just jarr
for more RL content. So thank you very
much